marx was interested in the relationship
of people in the process of production
that he's interested in the factory the
officer store what goes on and by that
he means what are the relationships
among the people that come together in a
workplace
and
what he analyzes is that there is
something going on there
that
has not been adequately understood
and that has not been adequately
addressed as an object needing
transformation
and what does he mean
the answer is exploitation which he
defines mathematically in the following
way
whenever in a society any society
you organize
people
adults not the children not the sick but
you know healthy adults
in the following way
a big block of them a clear majority
work that is they use their brains and
their muscles to transform nature a tree
into a chair a sheep into a woolen
sweater whatever
in in every human community marx argues
there are the people who do that work
but they always produce
more chairs more sweaters more
hamburgers than they themselves consume
whatever their standard of living
doesn't have to be low can be medium can
be high but they always produce more
than they themselves consume
that more by the way jer marx when he
writes this uses the german word mere
m-e-h-r which is the english equivalent
of more it's the more
that more got badly translated into the
word surplus
shouldn't have been but it was by by the
way by german and english people doing
the translations what's the difference
between war and surplus is there a
nuanced yeah because surplus has a
notion of it's discretionary it's sort
of extra
he's not taking a he's not making a
judgment that it's a simple math
equation yes very simple one minus the
other yes
x minus
x
x is the total output y is the
consumption by the producer therefore x
minus y equals s the surplus exactly
exactly
now marx argues
the ques the minute you understand this
you will ask the following question
who gets the surplus
who gets this extra stuff
that is made but not consumed by those
who made it
and marx's answer is
therein lies one of the great shapers of
any society how is that organized for
example who gets it
what are they asked if anything to do
with it in re in exchange for getting it
what's their social role
for example here we go now if you get
this and you get the core of it anyway
um
and i don't charge much um
the workers themselves could get less
than lawyers right that's right
uh the workers themselves could get it
yes that's the closest marx comes to a
definition of communism
communism would would be
if the workers who produce the surplus
together
decide what to do with it
so this has to do not just with who gets
it but more importantly who gets to
decide who gets it well who gets it and
who get gets to decide what to do with
it right
because you can't decide it if you don't
have disposition over it so the the lot
just the logic of the word sequence
it's produced it's marx uses the word
appropriated in other words whose
property who who gets to decide if you
like what happens all that property ever
meant is who gets to decide and who's
excluded that's a clean definition of
communism first right
and that's the by the way it's not just
clean it's the only one so what's uh can
we just linger on the definition of
exploitation yes context
easy becomes very easy to exploitation
exists if and when
the surplus that's produced is taken and
distributed by people other than those
who produced it slaves produces surplus
which the master gets
serfs produces surplus which the lord
gets
employees produce a surplus which the
employer gets
it's very simple
these are exploitative
class structures because one class
produces a surplus
appropriated
distributed
by another group of people
not the ones who produced it which
creates hostility enmity envy
anger resentment and all of the problems
you can lump under the heading
class
struggle i use a metaphor simple
metaphorical story you have two children
let's assume and you take them to
central park a few blocks from here it's
a nice day and the children are playing
and in comes one of those men with an
ice cream truck comes by dinga linga
lingaling your children see the ice
cream daddy get me an ice cream so you
walk over you take some money and you
get two ice cream cones and you give
them to one of the children
the other one begins to scream and yell
and howl
obviously what's the issue
and you realize you've just made a
terrible mistake
so you order
the one you gave the two ice cream cones
to give one of those to your sister or
your brother or whatever it is
and that that's how you solve the
problem
until a psychologist comes along and
says
you know
you didn't fix it by what you just did
you should never have done that in the
first place
my response so you understand
all of the efforts to deal with
inequality in
economic political culture these are all
giving the ice cream cone back to the
kid you should you should never do this
in the first place the reallocation of
resources creates bitterness populous
look at arva we've this country is
tearing itself apart now in a way that i
have never seen in my life and i've
lived here all my life and i've worked
here all my life
it's tearing itself apart and it's
tearing itself apart basically
over the redivision the redistribution
of wealth having so badly distributed in
the fir but that's all in marks
and notice as i explained to you
what is going on in this tension-filled
production scene in the office the
factory the store i don't have to say a
word about the government i'm not
interested in the government the
government's really of a very secondary
matter to this core question and here
comes the big point
if you make a revolution
and all you do
is remove the private exploiter
and substitute a government official
without changing the relationship
you know you can call yourself a marxist
all day long but you're not getting the
point of the marxism the point was not
who the exploiter is but the
exploitation per se you've got to change
the organization of the workplace so
there isn't a group that makes all the
decisions and gets the surplus
vis-a-vis another one that produces it
if you do that you will destroy the
whole project you will not only will you
not achieve what you set out to get but
you'll so
misunderstand it that you the germans
again have a phrase it's gear chief it
goes crooked it doesn't go right the
project gets off the rails because it
can't
uh it can't understand either what its
objective should have been and therefore
it doesn't understand how and why it's
missing its objective it just knows that
this is not what it had hoped for
you